another week and another steady dose of
Hogwarts Legacy news this time coming to
us from an unlikely Source the official
Hogwarts Legacy Instagram account but
only the Instagram account that's right
not Twitter not Facebook no YouTube just
the Instagram account it all started
with this post here with the picture of
a book and it says unauthorized or I
guess unauthorized guide to Hogwarts the
caption with the photo reads don't tell
the Headmaster consider this an
unauthorized guide to Student Life at
Hogwarts now to me this implies that it
was perhaps written by a student
especially when you consider the fact
that they don't want the Headmaster to
know about this they're also considering
it somewhat of an unauthorized guide so
it seems unlikely to come from a teacher
now what's interesting is if you go back
to the Autodesk presentation we can see
the book there and it looks like that
Professor Weasley could be the one who
is giving us this book which I know
would not match up with what I just said
but perhaps this scene is not Professor
we easily giving us this book but
perhaps it is her discovering this book
for the first time now that is not the
only place we have seen this book so far
we actually see it in the Gameplay
trailer as well if you take a look at
this scene right here we can see that
our character walks up to this little
bit of parchment here gets a prompt and
then they collect this parchment
immediately pull out the book and seem
to add this to the book to their
unauthorized guide of Hogwarts now there
is another similar scene with a page
floating in the air but on this one it
appears to be a different book or at
least a different cover but what I do
feel pretty confident about is that this
book is going to serve as our logbook
it's going to serve as the quest log and
it's very possible these various pages
that we find throughout Hogwarts are
tips and even secrets about the castle
itself in fact in the second entry of
that very same Instagram post we get
this right here a section that reads
common room secrets Hogwarts is full of
secrets the common rooms are no
exception tip number number one now our
third reveal here actually comes on this
very same shot right here it's down at
the bottom if you click way too fast you
just might miss it because we have some
additional handwriting here that seems
to be kind of fading out a little bit it
almost reminds me of the Half Blood
Prince book right because you have the
actual textbook and then you have these
areas where someone we don't really know
who yet is making these extra notes here
now this one we're not going to be able
to see everything that it says but I
feel pretty confident that it is
something to the effect of take
staircase to Kitchen go down hallway
third Barrel now of course this is in
reference to the entrance to the
Hufflepuff common room which we have
already seen long time fans of the
series will know exactly how you get in
the common room here but what's
interesting is in that exact spot in the
trailer we see this sort of shimmering
bit of parchment here it doesn't look as
solid as the one that we looked at
earlier but I think clearly these two
are connected here now the very next day
Wednesday Hogwarts Legacy had another
Instagram post I guess I'm gonna have
have to start checking my Instagram
actually I have an account but I hardly
ever use it it's so strange to me that
this is kind of like an exclusive
Instagram marketing push but whatever
I'll take any news however we can get it
so this next reveal here is all about
the restricted section of the library
and basically confirming something that
fans have wanted since this game once
announced heck since this game was
rumored fans have wanted to know can we
sneak around Hogwarts after hours can we
go areas we're not supposed to go like
the restricted section of the library
now the caption on this one reads this
next set of tips is not prefect approved
so basically I think this confirms that
prefects are going to be roaming the
castle like we remember from the old
school Harry Potter games like we
remember from the books trying to make
sure that students aren't out of bed
after hours or in the case of the
restricted section of the library just
that they're not in that area since
they're not supposed to be but hey
according to this tip here it's just a
suggestion but don't get caught so what
are the kind consequences of getting
caught here do we just lose house points
can we retry do we get immediately sent
back to our common room I can't wait to
see how exactly they handle that when we
fail and that was cited as tip number
two now I'm not going to consider this a
separate reveal here because this one's
a little bit hard to make out and
there's frankly not a lot that we can
see but at the top on this page here we
do get some additional handwriting as
well and really all I can make out of
this is two garlic they're not so
perhaps it could be talking about
something maybe a creature that is not
weak to garlic or it could always be
something to do with a potion ingredient
as well I think this one has to tie in
with Sebastian sallow's questline and
that family curse that we know about if
you think about it it all fits we go
back to the trailer and we see Sebastian
sneaking around in the Restricted
Section we already know that Sebastian
is trying to obtain shrivel figs and the
gamekeeper care magical creature
Professor not really sure which I think
it's probably gamekeeper but he tells
Sebastian we've been over this boy
shrivel fake cannot reverse a curse then
we also know he is in fact confirmed to
be sneaking around the restricted
section of the library and then we have
this note here about to garlic they're
not so I think this all ties into that
Quest and what he is trying to solve or
figure out regarding his family curse
now in that same Instagram post on the
next picture it is all about the defense
against the dark arts classroom tip
number three and this one reads the
classroom was made for Mischief like
meddling with Professor heckett's
hubridian black skeleton okay a couple
of things going on here Professor
heckett confirmed we saw that name in
the Autodesk presentation we didn't know
if it was Final it seems now that it was
in fact final and she is the defense
against the dark Hearts professor as far
as pronunciation goes a lot of people
think this is inspired by the Greek
goddess hekete or hekate I've heard some
people say so until we're told otherwise
I'm gonna go with professor heckett as
the pronunciation now we've also seen
this hybridian black skeleton in the
trailer as well ironically again tying
back to Sebastian here we see him cast
this spell and then the other student
kind of deflects it up it collides with
her herbertian black skeleton it starts
to fall and then of course she emerges
from her Chambers there and prevents it
from falling on the student so if you
weren't sure whether or not it was
written by a student I think this in
fact confirms at least the tips in this
book I don't know if the entirety of the
book will be written by a student but at
least the tips were definitely written
by a student I mean they're talking
about a classroom being made for
Mischief I don't think an adult like
Professor Weasley or anyone else would
put that in there yet again though that
is not the only reveal on this
particular picture here if you let this
one play out at the bottom right corner
you will see four spells written out and
surely they're confirmed for the game if
they're putting them here intentionally
I can't imagine that they would put them
here and then not have them in the game
but three of the Spells we actually did
not know were confirmed petrificus
totalus that is the one we see at the
top we've already seen that in the
trailer we see a square prompt for it
when our character is kind of sneaking
around we also see rictus simpra here
not rectum not rectum rictus simpra is
the pronunciation of that spell that of
course is the tickling charm then we
have ridiculous and the only known use
of ridiculous is to take down a Bogger
so I mean Bogart's confirmed I I feel
like they are and last but not least we
have Stupify I mean of course stupefy
had to be in this game that's probably
going to be like the main spell right
the main combat spell Stupify always a
good go-to but does this mean guys does
this mean we won't have full pindo the
most OP in the history of Harry Potter
well then on Thursday you guys already
know what's gonna happen another
Instagram post and another reveal this
one revealing tip number four peeves
avoid peeves at all costs the caption on
this one avoid peeves or don't peeves
was an absolute must for this game you
guys I'm so glad he's gonna be in here
and I don't know is Sebastian gonna be
like the most important side character
they have focused on him so much and
going back to him again the first time
we see Peeves in this game is in that
little clip of the Restricted Section
peeves is there with Sebastian causing
trouble and likely getting Sebastian
caught now what I love about this one
and what I love about peeps in this game
you guys is he is still wearing the Hat
now if you don't know the storyline of
this hat it's a pretty good one in 1876
there was an attempt by the current
Hogwarts caretaker his name was
rancorous carp he took it upon himself
to try and get rid of peeves now I'm not
gonna spoil it I'll let you go and read
the whole story for yourself I've
actually talked about it in a previous
video but no surprise it did not work
they did not get peeves to leave the
castle it was a catastrophic event and
it actually took the headmistor supraxia
mole bargaining with peeves to calm
everything down and one of his
requirements for him to give in and
surrender is he wanted a new hat made by
Madame bonable of Paris and so I think
this is that very same hat right here we
saw him wearing it earlier in the first
trailer we see him wearing it here again
I expect he'll be wearing it throughout
the entire game but then yet again if
you're not in the habit yet of looking
for the extra writing make sure you do
so you gotta wait and let the clip play
out and then right before it ends you
can kind of pause it and here we have
some additional text in the bottom right
corner yet again and this one I think
this is the biggest one of all this one
is super interesting and yet another
reveal confirming something that we
expected from the Autodesk session and
that is the name Professor sharp this
gentleman right here I'm just gonna go
ahead and say it confirmed as the
potions Master Professor sharp and the
text here I believe says ask about
sharps are or badge so it would seem
that not only is Professor sharp our
potions Master he is also a former auror
which right away makes me even more
interested in his character I can't wait
to hear about that backstory there we
already see he kind of has this limp
there was some speculation for a while
that maybe he is Phineas black I think
we could pretty much put that one to bed
at this point he is not finished is
black he is Professor sharp a former
auror now what's crazy is we continue to
get reveal after reveal heck I mean
probably the day that I put this video
out we very well could get another
Instagram post with more reveals so
we'll just kind of see how this goes
like maybe next week it's gonna be
Twitter maybe the next week is going to
be Facebook I don't know but right now
it seems like Instagram is the place to
be for these little Hogwarts Legacy news
tidbits now I still have some big
questions in fact I have three big ones
and I break them all down in the video
on the right side of your screen now
check that video out and let me know
which questions you still have about
Hogwarts Legacy as always thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon